preparing bottle feeds nappy changes and
sleepless nights babies can be demanding
but especially 15 week old bulu Marta
he's fed formula milk every four hours
kate diver is one of the four human
carers that have stepped in to try to
help raise the newly orphaned orangutans
he started to smile a bit more now he
started to play he's reaching out for
things and I think he's focusing more as
well on his surroundings and looking for
things and developing character more law
everyday the parent baby bond for
orangutans is unique infants stay with
their mother for seven years this was
bulu with his mum at Budapest zoo but
just a week after his birth she died
suddenly from intestinal problems so he
was brought to europe's only orangutan
crash where they're hoping he'll
eventually be adopted by a new mum and
learn the essential survival skills
he'll need it's vitally important that
Billy Martin lands to fend for himself
because Sumatran orangutans are now
critically endangered that means now
there's only 7,000 of them left in the
wild
that isn't even identifying 7,000
individuals that's based on an estimate
of what habitat might be remaining and
we know that every day that's getting
smaller and smaller so the little boy is
actually incredibly rare he's too small
to mix with his new playmates just yet
but the aim is to help Billy Marta to
live as normal a life as possible so he
can go on to have his own babies with
the orangutan population in decline
providing nature with a little helping
hand has never been more important KT
Spencer Sky News